joining us now in a Canadian television
exclusive interview is Ukraine's Chief
negotiator in this Warren leader of
velodimir zielinski's servant of the
people party David arahamiya thank you
for being with us Mr arahamiya you're a
close advisor to the president you've
been with him since day one how have you
changed this past year and how has he
changed
that's a good question thank you I think
I did not change at least I'm not seeing
myself changed a lot as for zelenski he
became I think he became less
patient in terms of you know like before
every time that something bad happens so
he tried to analyze and you know ask
everybody interrogate what happened and
how we could avoid it in the future now
he has no more time for this so if the
person fails he just like puts him out
of the team immediately second thing I
think emotionally he also like became
kind of a harder person now because he
saw so many you know uh bad things
happened around him you know like it was
the Ukrainian people so he kind of
became tougher
now China has come up with a proposed
peace plan on the anniversary do you
think it could lead anywhere
well the good sign is China started to
feel that they also need to participate
in some kind of you know mitigation of
the war because before if you took a
look for a year they tried to pretend
that nothing happened
so it's a good sign that in their ideas
or concepts they saying that we have to
obey United Nations statute which uh you
know which has to respect the the legal
borders of the country so it plays for
us
is that that sign I think is that there
was no single word about uh a call to
Russian troops to go back
behind our borders so it's not
acceptable for us but we should consider
China I think because China is so big
and powerful it remains uh kind of a
neutral so the the so far we have no
evidence that they are supporting Russia
with weapons or you know special
military technologists we just like need
to to talk to them and uh see if their
intentions are really serious or those
intentions are just politics
what gives you hope right now
my hope that our counter-offensive
operation
in the summer I think it will come the
summer maybe early early autumn
will be successful and will give a very
very clear signal to Russians so to sit
down and sign the deal on our terms This
Is My Hope
do you think you'll be sitting down at
the negotiating table again
well you know like diplomats I'm not a
professional Diplomat you know like but
I got so many advisors on this you know
like I talked to so many people around
the world and everybody is saying that
all wars eventually end with uh on the
negotiation table
so whatever you know War it is whatever
scale it is it always end up in the same
place you know like so that's why it's
inevitable
David arahamiya thank you so much for
your time
it's a little bit likewise thank you
very much